citizens of the reject Nation I want to thank
all of you guys who have been joining us for
the Ahsoka reactions and now we're here for the
Ahsoka finale but more importantly I want to
thank everyone who bought this shirt the real
Rex exclusive one that just came in the mail
for him w got it just in time baby real reject
exclusive Ahsoka snip snip lightsaber scissors
you get it that's what I'm talking about and of
course real reject has other exclusive Star Wars
related type of shirts as well we got our Pedro
Pascal from last of us carrying grou our child
protection services shirt of course we got our
aoda t-shirt and then you know our classic space
babies and we got other shirts as well like our
who influences The influencers Watchman inspired
tea and then we got a whole bunch more it is one
of the absolute best ways to support the channel
September was our most successful month thank you
guys so much for supporting the channel helps pay
for people like Michael Tesla or Star Wars offici
UT to beer how are you Michael you excited I'm
paid that's great news you at the end of the year
I'm so excited are you excited I am a so excited
John who yeah I've Sabine waiting for this use
the force to leave a like ladies and gentlemen
as always full length Reaction watch along this
where you sync up with your own copy of Ahsoka
available for our super sexy rejects over at our
patreon page thank you to all who have joined us
for the journey for Ahsoka over there but we also
cover several things exclusively with reaction
highlights and watch along included let's see what
this episode is all about and if it sticks The
Landing let's go please be great please be
great Kevin CER Music Man keeps
killing it ever since he got fired off
Yellowstone once again kudos to the VFX team they
have a fix on the Jed sh location dispatch two
Tie fighters if they find their Mark tell them
to engage and find me a tailor I need to bring
are old timey and outdated there is little
the Jedi can do to stop us now even I fell
victim to the heroics of a single Jedi Star
Wars Rebels references they had to be there
we are grateful to you Grand Admiral and to you
Morgan elth all she wanted was to be appreciated
dude it's your time is she going to get what she
wants or is she about to get the axe you shall be
rewarded with sacrifice the gift of Shadows
gift of Shadows I'm so excited to see this
who whoa eight yes oh wow sweet yes
sweet welcome whoa those
eyes sound some freaky [__] today I know
a thr does not like any of this
man he really kills it with the
music blade yes the blade eat it up
Morgan take it take it sister sister
all right that's sick go forth and kick
an ass oh wow great upgrade from a best
our spear that's a big uh got a feeling that
uh grou and Company are going to see that one
day that's great shot great shot all right there's
a prologue for you I think it's going to be okay
three and a half out of five Jedi the witch
in The Warlord nice flying the witch in The
Wardrobe it's just like such a funny thing
to do with the title I love it the thonic
of death Amir thonic no no that's not going
to work look not going to work what are you
talking about the blade emitter is too narrow
even this set looks were colorful even though
we've seen this set before stop that everything
in here is organized yeah disorganized I have a
system this will be his third lightsaber I
have a system who taught you how to build
a lightsaber anyway Kanan jerus hell yeah Caleb
D and I taught him how to build a lightsaber of
course now it all makes sense how could you
know him I taught almost every youngling at
the Jedi Temple when he was Caleb boy Caleb
was very curious how old are you old enough
to know that the relationship between a master
and an apprentice is as challenging as it is
Meaningful amen old enough for True wisdom my
guy faid tenant really knocked it out of the
park dror huyang is killing it yeah that's
it I had two of them Kanan took the one the
other I held on to in case he ever needed it
oh that's great oh that's a amazing thank you
H it's red it's the deepest red everyone who was
complaining last episode sted it looks like you
were a good student unlike some students Bean
ahoka ever teach you how to oh get back here
Ahsoka became afraid that Sabine was training
as a Jedi for the wrong reasons after what
happened on mandelo oh boy killing hundreds
of thousands her family were all lost sadly
oh man aera felt that if Sabine unlocked her
potential she would become dangerous give to
the dark side your gamble paid off so you know I
do it's okay I'm white now I'm chill about this
stuff they stand side by side
sorry know I know is that a reference to
something that was a joke internet can't
imagine what it could be made my share
of difficult choices no one understood
my reasons except my master I love whenever
you talk about Anakin talk Anakin to me he
always stood by me even when no one else
did now you must do the same for Sabine no
matter what happens next I'm going to be there
for you I hope you don't regret those words
now a smile have you kept up with your training
I try there's no trying I do being a Jedi isn't
about wielding a lightsaber what it helps
especially in our situation train your mind
train your body work harder on yourself trust
and the force and go to therapy VIs visualize
dream board see that's why it was okay that
Ezra didn't use a lightsaber last episode
guys could really use the [Laughter]
lightsaber me now oh all right
we've lost the stabilizer
oh wow
man imagine the send of the two of them just
getting crushed we held on as long as we
could these guys are so
[Music] Eerie fly right into him
boom same combo naughty looks
right right at the camera oh
boy well that's that's a
problem not a scratch he like
I've had the ship for 300
years got
him oh these poor guys poor shell gang this
is going to slow us down a bit only if we let
it h i love ahsoka's K do attitude the successful
strike on the Jedi shuttle was reported before we
lost contact with the flight group an acceptable
outcome I think he is perfect that he's still
giving citations even in this we should prepare
for a ground assault good immediately better more
action yes lead them Gandalf [Music] yeah we
need some giant eagles in here next a be with
you and also with you lift up your sa and with
your spirit look at that it's a classic Western
shot right there the blessing of the great
mothers shall protect you in battle against
the Jedi I cannot wait for thraw and Ahsoka
to finally meet face to face and for Ahsoka
to fight all will honor to make the sacrifice
for the Empire the security of our galaxy the
security of our galaxy that's an important
line cuz there is a greater threat how's it
going you've kept her in this guy longer than I've
been alive yes I'll be so upset if who Yang's Left
Behind thrawn found this place woke up the witches
rebuilt his Starship woke up the witches well
you're not alone anymore let's try the front
door R right up to the Fortress walls that's
interesting so we specifically sought this place
out there's something larger at play rain Hellfire
upon them there been no negotiating with The
Apprentice of Anakin Skywalker sick he feels the
threat this is seriously the Lord of the Rings
wow oh my God Jesus D BL rain hell from above
Death from Above I mean it's nice to know that
even the Star Destroyers don't know how to shoot
straight whoever designs the weapons
for them Sabine help out come on
Sabine this feels like a Star Wars
video game that's exactly what it feels
like oo yes oh jez that was
uncomfortable pull together thr hold
together dispatch the night triers
and bring me my brown uniform
I think there might be some
Undead elements perhaps a this is sick
interesting that we just cut to this I
know fall back draw them out do like
the shot of the three lightsabers saine
Blaster General Ahsoka there we go
Ezra with a lightsaber oh man come
on baby oh
boom that was a baby great shot
that's still her show still her
show nice she was so it was so calm a so calm oh
boy yes come on oh it's it's going to happen they
going to resurrect yes I so Hing necromancy so
hoping for this this this has been the dream of
Star Wars fans for a long time yes nice theories
confirmed I was going to say like it was it
was sudden how like just Victorious and easy
going that was yeah yeah they know the regular
Troopers ain't [__] this ever happened before
no this is new lucky us we'll just keep taking
them down they still suck at shooting yes yeah
now they're probably a little worse that they
even move like zombies o oh man for Halloween
season God they are like a hoorde aren't
they force push them away and they have less
fear some of them are even trying to use their
guns God just the growls the eyes the microphones
yeah he's going to bite you you're going to
turn careful careful oh yeah nice
oh go good job with the lightsaber
a training paying off uhoh thank God all
doors closed when you hit them see the
default nice moves she's been training
what's your excuse I missed you a like
sci-fi doors are always programmed to
do the opposite when you destroy them
if they're closed they open if they're open
they closed we are ready to depart grandad
yeah they make it on board the
ship we require a little more
time you got to stay behind
and fight I understand is
that what's happening she seems committed for the
Empire this this dude's playing all [Music]
along you were just used as a backup plan
good luck wow I actually feel kind of bad
for her right traveled to the other Galaxy
man Justice for Morgan El Beth no she's she's
done uh everything she promised I'm excited for
the rematch with Ahsoka we need you to have
a boss battle there we go I was going to say
man this is way too short of a threat that
seems like a Sabine and Ezra problem while
ahoka gets the rematch it's cool that we're in
like a castle Siege now like the king arthan
Vibes go on I'll handle this let's see
what happens you must stop throwing
she was a formidable opponent she was
this is the way and now she's got some
powers
oh yeah
sick oh I love the sound [Music] design a
love the overhead shot too okay this is a
good looking fight yeah this is a day
floting type fight oh my gosh whoa oh
yeah that was well done man oh it got chills from
that fight add some new things to the Lucas Sound
Library The ilm Sound
Library oh yeah
[__] Best Care ouch God these guys
punches finally got that trailer shot
yeah I'm having fun with the episode but
I am a feeling of lack of tension at the
same time sure but at the same time I
don't know where we're going take us
out maybe we're going going oh boy oh my God
are they going to actually get separated from
huyang I like a lot of these
action visual shots though
whoa show it sick pull the helmet off
Force push them do the thing you were
doing come it's time Focus life
for death just jiggle it a little
bit I'll be happy with that yeah oh look at that
mouth don't be a fake out hey
as it Ezra see kylo well done
sned
oh that trailer reaction oh I got so
much crap for say she was force sensitive
Vindicated but can she Force jump doesn't matter
let her fall to her [Music] death I think this
is a very well choreographed fight I 100% agree
uh-oh not so tough without your [Music] goons oh
okay yeah the cacophony of all this stuff stacking
on top of her is good that's just some uh Order 66
flashbacks for her we can't hit that all right
who yangang you can't make that jump yes you
can oh she can't give him Force push you first
and you pull me across whoa and that's teamwork
I can do this what you can do is call up on the
space bu imagine traveling to a different galaxy
only to accidentally kill azra the longer you
hesitate the harder get come on okay go no for
thing damn sa nice oh oh Jesus that's all red who
you he it's a thick platform okay baby baby it's
great shot come on your turn Ahsoka did you see
me I can't leave her is Ahsoka actually going to
get stranded she got hyang she still got hyang
and Balin oh my God a this is there's a lot oh
no everyone stop shooting yeah this is too
good to miss yeah sh wow wow wow wow gain your
composure you guys are going to have to learn to
get along you will die here alone
no alone not alone oh hell yeah hey
hey my man I'm really proud of her I
know right and it's full circle it's
nice wow she is found her balance she
knows Ezra's okay she come back for
Ahsoka where the hell is Balin oh
yeah maybe they already set up the
[Music] movie
oh oh wow oh I didn't actually want her to die I
know I really a same she was just
like o well she has done what was
required Justice for morg than
L's back like how you see thraw
being like keep it together keep
it together 757 here ass this is
Jaa this Lando Cal that little boy game
on his oh my God he's literally doing
it where's AZ he going home oh are they
going to get left behind I'm right behind
you hey a Mandalorian Jedi have
the main batteries Target The
Fortress for bombardment affirmative
Grand Admiral but that's that's our
home wow SI shot yeah not their shots
though yes hey Back to the Future to the
Future later butt heads Ahsoka I used the
force did you see my training
look it all comes crumbling
down man thron's going to be real grumpy
about this can we catch him I am diverting
all power to the engines oh feeling
this suspense it's back it's back people
I just I don't genuinely know if we're going
to get there I love it I love these shots so
much come on make the ship that thing is H make
the ship allow me to commend you on your efforts
today they meet I regret we haven't met face to
face and perhaps now we never shall God Dam it
come on I know you because I knew your Master oh
she's going to oh no one wonders just how similar
you might become a confirmation he knows this is
where a ronin such as sh belongs Ronin a sonin
today victory is mine so close oh he's taunting
long live the Empire no no yeah oh [__] oh
[__]
sheeps oh my God o could to make you
feel the force against you don't worry
guys we'll get season two in like three
years very satisfying followup well Ezra
can hijack the ship and go back yes all by
himself you know there's kind of poetry to
him going with [Music] thrawn we are the new
ezas we are your new human overlords guess
this explains where Ahsoka was during the
rise of the first order and but what about
Ezra Morse wait a second morai
I wonder if there's another way
back speaking of that's the first time we
saw it like like an actual live
action right yeah I think [Music]
so oh oh she found her
people I guess this is where her Destiny called
her to wow super Lord of the Rings oh my God
that looks a lot like the father right that
that's his beard right oh a total oh my god
wow oh my God it's exactly oh it's so he found
it's the mother gleaming beacon the the exiled
mother is that's right cuz there's only father
daughter and son and she was exiled and daughters
with Ahsoka oh my God you're right yeah look
at that shot which might make Balin the Sun
that's huge that's really big and they're going
straight to damir and they're going to start
resurrecting bring me
Maul very Spiel bergy they're Wheeling the ark
down there just now damn that's a big ass ending
reveal of Balin for his One Moment In the episode
too is that asra is he going to get reunited yes
hey how was zra I pretend to be
on the dark [Laughter] side uh
maybe helmet off first dramatic effect is great
but it's Chopper trying to say
Chopper no Chopper trying to
say how how can Chopper tell it's Chopper it's for
sensitive hey
[Music] buddy
vinra and I know the perfect Padawan for
him oh yeah hi Hara I'm home yeah you
are don't worry about a so will be yes at least
they know where to go to get them yeah well how
the heck do you get there got to find some
more perill if there's one person who can do
it it's almost like Ahsoka needed to come here
to fulfill the mortis Ark it makes sense it all
comes back to that even when we first discovered
World Between Worlds you know thanks to you Ezra
got home do you have confirmation of that just not
here I hope look at that pragmatist Ezra is where
he needs to be and so are we oh man dude you get
so in tune with the force here it's time to move
on they're both going to have big
beards by the next season what is
it I felt like a disturbance in
the forest something familiar
nothing no say it just shadows in
a Starlight bars shadows in the
Starlight Anakin I think so Force goost
Anakin muasa Cloud Anakin
please
I would love if they pan up to an Anakin
shaped constellation just winking one
eye yes
dude do not look happy no no he's
he's wow he looks even better than he did in the
Return of the Jedi special edition that a rick
F ricka look at that oh wow that was fun I am
I am satisfied I started off in a way where I
was like I'm enjoying it Uh something's kind of
like missing in suspense and then the last half
I really thought really brought it man and then
some big things to talk about we got some we got
some things to talk about we're getting an Ezra
Bridger show and Jace I just what a great pairing
and a perfect master I know to go from Kanan to
Ezra from Ezra to Jace that'd be awesome it also
would be great if we keep them separate from
Luke so they don't all get slaughtered by KY
all righty guys well we got some talking points
to hit here we got things we got to go over um if
you are listening to this on Apple or Spotify uh
please rate this video that we just watched Ahsoka
finale um oh no we got to do our generals out of
the way generals um John what would you rate it
out of 10 uh eight I give this one a solid eight
that was pretty good that was pretty thrilling
what would you give it I would give it a general
Kenobi come on what's that honestly honestly I'm
just impressed I'm impressed that they got as
much done they it's a nine wow it's a nine it's
a nine Disney shill over here Disney shill yeah
easy to Disney do me a favor if if I'm gonna be
such a shill pay me already I've racked up a lot
of credit I would argue no I mean I've given this
series I think some Fair criticisms over the
course but I think this was a tough finale and
I think they wrapped it up in a way that I'm
satisfied excited and I have questions but I
also got answers yeah how about you Greg four
out of 10 okay this about Fair yeah yeah really
want to balance the scales I agree I'm balanced
four Bal I got to edit so I'm gonna delay this
even more to make life more stressful for me
no I would uh i' would actually meet John at
an eight actually yeah I'm I'm about an eight
I have some criticisms about the episode uh but
over all no um there's a lot that I really like
I probably bump it up to like an 8.1.7 five by
the time that we're Nott way to go I'll probably
go down to an eight by the time I'm done talking
if this was Rotten Tomatoes I'd be like 83% yeah
sure yeah yeah yeah all right then um so okay uh
John please since you are the lowest of us yes
since I am what are your general thoughts we'll
call this chapter John's General thoughts John's
[__] uh no I liked this episode I thought yeah
yeah I was having certain reservations similar to
yours earlier on being like okay you know this is
thrilling and immediate but is this going to be
as satisfying as like a season finale needs to
be and this isn't necessarily like the big allout
punctuation you know that you might expect from
a a series fin a season finale but you know
the pace of the series up until now has kind
of led me to expect something that felt and you
know was scaled a bit more like this is clearly
part of an ongoing story that will probably span
out as you guys have speculated past Ahsoka into
other spin-offs and whatnot that all said uh I
thought the developments with like seeing the
night sisters do their thing and the night uh
Troopers and all that stuff like that scratches
itches for me just as like a witchcraft love and
horror person but beyond that I thought this made
for a an appropriately thrilling immediate and
you know palpable uh end chapter and by the time
we get to those finale moments of like them doing
the alley push of Ezra on to the ship and Morgan
El's best's fight with Ahsoka and you know them
making the sacrifice to at least get one of them
home the person we came here for home all those
things coales to be pretty satisfying to me in
the end and then the stuff setting up for the
future especially with like even though I have
no idea kind of what you guys are talking about
when it comes to what Balin is looking for like
the amalgamation of his presence up till now plus
the Striking he think he can do it better than the
Nazis yes so he's looking for the dial of Destiny
to go back he needs to go back so that he can kill
Hitler and then take place it's not on Disney
plus no no no no no it's okay it's not that's
not what it's about but but uh ask okay Michael
but even that stuff got me very intrigued like
I was like oh I cannot wait to find out or or
at least I'm very excited to find out what uh
the next step of his journey will be tragedy of
his loss as an actor as side all that stuff you
know piqu my interest in this did all the things
I think a finale is supposed to do to you so yeah
sure yeah I dug it yeah man all right here's
my general thoughts really quick my general
thoughts are from the following several months
ago did a trailer reaction of sooka and there
were many comments many many comments and I'm just
going to read the top comment won't say the name
because I confidently said not even questionably
or apprehensively said Sabine is force sensitive
oh and the top comment was saine is not force
sensitive one of the top comments s's not force
sensitive she's one of the few non-force sensitive
people to wield a lightsaber and then goes on to
explain stuff basically but it's a whole bunch
of back and forth in the comments 67 replies
about how she's not force sensitive and I would
have been part of that camp I was like no she is
that's that's 67 plates of crow we got to serve
up now boom this episode went to a 10 out of 10
for me just who's sensitive [Laughter] now see
that ego stroking it yeah stroke that ego like a
lightsaber stroke that everybody like a lightsaber
uh you stoke to lightsaber it would cut it would
melt your hand I I i' actually what about Morgan
Elis i' I'd actually agree I know she was talking
on the side it was interesting uh I'd actually
agree with wasen a lightsaber I'd agree with with
everything you you said John actually if you want
to know my general thoughts skip to John's General
thoughts and then go Greg sounds like those are
Greg's General thoughts are are we putting them on
an infinite Loop of just rewatching that segment
but I'm just I guess I'm more ex I really like the
F I'll just add to like I really like the fight
choreography quite a bit um like just to add on
a couple of other things you were saying like yeah
some of that tension was a little bit missing for
me when you know like they they go into like it's
it was fun I wouldn't say thrilling it was fun and
then they go into the temple then just like Cuts
two and they're just fighting the night Troopers
I was like something feels off about the editing
here like what are they trying to sell me on and
while I like the gracefulness of Ahsoka fighting
there was also something where I felt like she
wasn't really playing to anything physical like
I could feel like the Detachment of green screen
and stuff so that was some of the things that
was kind of like uh undercutting it for me when
necromancy night Trooper thing happened I thought
that was really U I thought that was really fun
that was really cool and then that's when the
suspense and ex and and intrig started really
build for me and I really did love the last half
of this and I thought the Morgan Elizabeth fight
uh with Ahsoka I thought the choreography was
great I love when they do you got like multip
people lightsabers and blades and whatnot and
what I think is really impressive is when you
can demonstrate the different types of fight
choreography style while putting it in one fight
you know because they're they're very distinct
fighting styles and I thought like towards the
end I was really gripped and I loved everything
they set up like the T I did not I thought it
was going to be something more Zeo related you've
been going more chis route which is still there
still there oh yeah I I'm holding firm on that um
and you think with what this planet has in store
that uh that that because it's like I think
Thon we'll talk more about it but something I
thought was interesting like Thon is constantly
you know downplaying the Jedi but from being on
this planet you think he but but I think I think
he does I don't think he ever necessarily downplay
the right that's not the right call downplaying
he talks down to the J about the Jedi uh but no
he definitely doesn't down downplay would mean he
doesn't find the threat but he was clar like no we
got to eliminate these guys I agree with that but
I feel like his mentality is very similar to like
you know in in episode four when all the Imperial
officers are talking to Vader about like you know
your wacky your wacky order you know and I think
it's a similar they fought a a a worthless Crusade
and you know he looks down on them because they
were so easily manipulated but but but um Mel
dude yeah um um as as as somebody that like loved
the expanded universe growing up in playing all
the games reading bunch of the comics reading the
books this was like the nicest Love Letter uh in
so many ways like and and they did it in a way
that did feel inauthentic in a way that didn't
feel unearned which I honestly think is the most
impressive part about this finale like did it give
me everything I wanted no but everything that
we did get I felt like we deserved it based on
everything that's happened development character
growth even Sabine like they could have gone
overboard and I think what they did with being
able to grab the lightsaber and do the push it
was it was exactly about as far as I feel that
she deserved to get uh in terms of of the force
um and it was I think it's impressive up until
the end I I really I didn't know who's going to
land where um and I think in a in an age of like
such predictability it was so nice to genuinely
be like oh wow that's that's a surprising twist
that has completely like any like pre-existing
theories that people have or like Investments of
of time into uh into where they thought this was
going has now been thrown off course yet again
yeah um and I'm genuinely excited and intrigued
by all the seeds that were planted uh that being
said like the action sequences like they were they
were fun I had a lot of fun and and um talk about
the ones Michael the ones talk about the ones so
we call this chapter the ones the ones so you know
for for those that watch the Clone Wars uh like we
know the mortise Arc uh and something that like
we've been saying and the whole Internet's been
saying is like well they they're setting Anakin
up to be the father you know Ahsoka to potentially
be the daughter Ezra to be the Sun but I don't
think that's happening anymore I wonder if maybe
Bal fits that role um but I think think what
we've officially set ourselves up for in kind
of this like this overarching the force behind
the force is aith who is the mother and we only
ever saw aith in I think it was 2008 2009 uh the
fate of the Jedi book series which is like one of
the last like expanded universe pieces and she is
like like her title is like the bringer of chaos
or something to that effect um and is one of the
most like horrifying horrific misbalances of the
force and presents an existential threat not just
to the Galaxy but to the Galaxy's plural and to
the force and and the balance of it as a whole and
uh this idea of like a old gray Jedi who survived
Order 66 who is kind of done everything he can
to get to this galaxy to go on this Quest I'm
so excited to like I would just watch Balin with
no other characters go on this journey and would
be a happy happy camper um but they you know this
was an arc that one of the few that George Lucas
really gravitated towards and actually adapted
from the books into the Clone Wars ARC and I'm
sure Dave Fon had a hand in that um but this to me
seems like I don't know what the treatments of you
know 78 and N uh were that George Luc was dreaming
up and had offered to Disney uh but I've got a
feeling the wills I've got a feeling that we're
seeing it yeah um uh at least an extent of it um
you know it's it's well then you also got James
mangle's movie which is supposed to be the like
the is it the origin of the Jedi or something the
origin of the Jedi which I think is the perfect
I I think we'll probably see aith in her prime
yeah um and maybe even that whole I mean I'm so
curious what would be the most efficient ient way
to describe like the father son and daughter they
are the physical representations of the balance
of the force yeah um and so the father being the
epitome of balance and keeping light and darkness
from consuming one another and from one becoming
too powerful yeah the the mother is a factor that
we haven't seen and how that plays in and in a way
and this is what I'm really really hoping for
Anakin's story could theoretically continue as
he takes on this role like his his role of the
chosen one to bring balance of the force based
on everything that they've set up was for him
to become the father after the father died in
it's been a couple years since I've seen that
just rewatched if I'm not if my memory serves
me correct didn't the father want Anakin to take
was it the son's place or his place his place his
place he he wanted to see Theos one in to see
if it was true and when it when the Reckoning
came part of explaining to Anakin that he was the
chosen one was showing him what he will become in
the form of Vader and that is ultimately I think
what what pushed him away from it um but notice
how in the time that the father died the balance
of the force has since been completely off right
and now there is this opportunity to remedy yet
um but I I think that you know so so like what
what in the Clone Wars dat when it was like ob1
uh Ahsoka and Anakin were on an adventure then
they got pulled into it's just it's called mortise
they got pulled into mortise and that's where they
met them on this like beautiful imagine like uh
Legend of Zelda and Nintendo DS Lally theor and
uh and yeah they got the and the and the sun was
like uh his father son daughter and like the way
they're this like ethereal way they're all drawn
and one of them has a big beard one of them has a
big beard has a big beard which I saw carved in
the stone that's great catch that's great catch
and the sun kind of looks like a grand Inquisitor
like like the yeah it's from do the kids represent
chaos or or airing toward one side of the spectrum
or the the daughter is the light the son is the
darkness and then Ahsoka died and in this Arc and
then was brought back to life by the daughter okay
res like giving her giving her giving her life
force into her and and that bird that we saw
morai uh is a representation of that and following
her out but the question I have is Ahsoka doesn't
remember any of that right if I'm not mistaken
that's right they don't remember any of that I
think the there is only bits and pieces um did not
think this would be the like such a thing we were
be talking about in this episode well damn that's
the ending they set it up it's what they it's it's
playing into the and I I'm hopefully what this
origin of the Jedi movie will be is getting into
like like the crazy like spirituality of the force
and like the idea of balance and light Darkness
felon's evolved in that Jedi movie I'm hopefully
hopefully well I think it has to be I it would
be a waste of of they've they've made so many
positive strides in telling a cohesive narrative
um and and I think it's great it it takes away
some characters that we care about and puts them
in an arc that is equally important in an entirely
different galaxy um and that has really high
stakes um well also like bringing back Ezra and
allowing us to like continue I mean Ezra is going
to be such a great addition to the Mandalorian
team up you know and all that totally agree but
what is what how is Balin like he want he keeps
talking about um obtaining a power power well how
how would he obtain a power from I think in the
same way that Anakin and Ahsoka were brought to
Morse Balin has been summoned to this Galaxy and
he has been through the force aith who has been
literally like like if I'm remembering correctly
and it's been a while like she was banished and
locked away and kept away like which is why we
don't see her in the mortise Arc crazy [__] and
so this idea of you know the repres your mother is
insane woman represents chaos they can't control
Bal probably thinks he is finding that balance
when in reality he is unleashing chaos uh and I I
think ultimately uh Balin is a fascinating choice
for the Son and the because we never did get a
replacement for you know who's going to fill that
that void um and Anakin Ahsoka and Balin I would
just watch that I would just watch them talk to
each other about like who how's the weather today
I mean Force ghost Anakin is a great thing to be
bringing into here because one thing that excites
me as like what what I would would have informed
of via the comments you guys is that Hayden
Christian said didn't act he did actually consume
Clone Wars uh he he went back and he watched all
of it he ate TVD well oh no I mean it because that
was one of the great things about his performance
was it it felt like it was informed by all of the
progress of the yeah he was bringing the animated
performance to life it was a great marriage of
what he did in the prequels and then what you
see in the animated shows and I so every time
he's there I'm like I love seeing him because
he's he's doing it he's doing it all he just seems
so happy to be here he does he does seem happy to
be here and with them being stranded here with
all the Jedi training that could be taking place
of course with Ahsoka and Sabine we'll get some
present day interaction that is not so much of an
ethereal Wonderland of like World Between Worlds
but something more AK to like when Luke interacts
with Obi-Wan's ghost or when Luke interacts with
Yoda oh was almost it it very similar I mean even
in timing of you know in the Obi-Wan series
it took that entire experience for Obi-Wan to
be able to see Qui-Gon and to be able to commune
with him in the force and I think for Ahsoka this
is finally the not only has she come to terms
with him and and what went wrong but she's also
come to terms with herself and where she wronged
her Padawan and uh I think that balance will be
really helpful for all of them um yeah I'm just
so curious because you also have Shin which like
that's just an open-ended fascinating where is
she G to go like there's there's I think there's
still a lot more there um she found her people
yeah but but that's whatever the hell's going
on there that's a temporary I rule you now uh I
mean same uh this is great huh isn't this baren
Wasteland awesome I mean I hope it amounts
to more than just her being there to create
fun scenes next season we're going to kick these
naughties asses every day going to bully going to
go like this for centuries have some Turtle suit
uh perpetuate a cycle of violence yeah I mean
what's what's next on our on our list here I mean
we were talking about Force ghost Anakin which I'm
very much excited about we covered mortise um the
one morai uh I I guess I would like to talk about
Morgan elsabeth next that' be fun what a great
character great execution a villain with motive
that I believed an actor that just I think knocked
it out of the park I think she brought more to it
than the writing brought to it h thousand like
I think the writing was very like I there filon
is one of those writers like conceptually I think
he is a [__] F genius conceptually speaking and
what he adds to Universe building is phenomenal
times though like his dialogue is not the greatest
you know and sometimes his character development
is not the greatest uh in terms of how to write
certain sometimes it is really great like he's
written some of the best Star Wars you will have
ever seen all right I I got to just say like he's
written some amazing Star Wars content and then
there are other times where it does feel I I don't
he's get it feels like I'm watching like a really
neat outline and uh sure and and and that's the
part where it can lack for me and I think like you
can see the right and Morgan eleth is a case too
where I felt like there was so much more richness
to mine from her or or to really develop that I
was en I really enjoyed her presence here and um
I I actually like the reveal of how Thon was just
like yep go when I need your out of her you don't
really matter to me like yeah but when she does
die it is a bummer to me a because I thought there
was more to really we could have done with her and
be you know to have her set up in the Mandalorian
again like I really love the writing of filoni's
writing in that episode I thought that was really
great yeah that's one of the strongest episodes
and he directed that one too usually when he
directs and writes it's really strong um and and
then uh it does feel like we didn't really get get
enough out of her it was just she was mainly here
just giving information like all all season it's
just she's just giving information she gave a main
supporting character performance to a role written
like a main Hench just like you know she had a lot
of presence and I would have loved to have peered
through that character's perspective especially
being that she is being inducted gradually into
this hor of death religion yeah yeah you know
there's so much that's interesting about that
and that expands just what this world deals with
I think all of this flirts with going into the
more Fantastical the more spiritual the Le like
Star Wars has all that but I'm used to seeing the
technological sci-fi side of that where I feel
like through her you could have rung some rich
drama especially out of what appeared in Lars
mikkelson's performance like a calculated move
like not not oh it's unfortunate but this is what
needs to be done it's sort of like no Now's the
Time for this move I anticipated where I'm gonna
sacrifice you oh dude yes thanks for segueing
us John Thon Michael Michael thon's thon's plan
Thon th wants to go to damir there there wants to
resurrect Darth Maul for the third there was a uh
there was that one line of protecting the Galaxy
that I was like oh I'm a treasure prot there
there she is what we've been building up towards
um I it could go so many directions I mean the
obvious one is they're going to resurrect whoever
whether it be the witches of damir or or more
dead Storm Troopers it could be a meta commentary
on rewriting the Star Wars Canyon so that would
practice against Kathleen Kennedy that's exactly
what it is sa the Galaxy from Kathleen Kennedy
I mean guys right clickbait and Ryan Johnson I'm
excited to ever gonna get to that new Trilogy
yeah probably not um but uh you know I I think
we're looking at it a head-to-head clash with the
Imperial Remnant and all that I just I hope they
don't waste thrawn on like joining up with the
emperor and the whole Sith Eternal and all that I
just like I'm it doesn't do anything for me uh on
a story level and I think the far more interesting
situation would be for Thon to get back for him
to get all the Imperial Remnant together and for
them to fraction off because he's like we need to
save the Galaxy from this external threat and the
other ones are going on the The Witch Hunt to try
to find Palpatine uh which at at some point like
that needs to connect because some of those
folks end up going that route there's great
drama to ring out of a situation like like I think
that's a Show's worth I don't think that's a movie
yeah honestly like I feel like a movie might
rush that [__] well I part of me wonders if
we're missing some of the shows that are gonna
be coming out this there there's a waight to e
like they got Ezra back and and uh and and and
man I am just blinking on everyone's names this
episode that's fun no no Hera God damn it so and
Hera um is right about Thon being a threat and
it's like but at what cost was it to to be right
and what Co like what cost was it to bring back
Ezra if it led to Thon returning unless unless
th would have return unless the thon's purpose
is to protect the Galaxy from a greater threat
which I continue from the grisk you or the yuzan
Vang depending on you know yeah what you want
to call them but you know I I think that's an
interesting setup for a um you know you could also
see like the creation of the resistance you know
this idea of like part of why Leia created it
in the first place is because the new Republic
wasn't taking the Imperial remnant seriously
right um so you know and then the question is
like is Luke getting involved like there's just I
have so many questions and no answers but I think
they need a thraw show in order to properly tell
that side of the story I think it would just be
nice if if maybe bringing thrawn back to the mess
that is the new Republic and the Imperial Remnant
like I think it would be a great opportunity for
some characters to survey all of that and go like
none of you are doing this right right yeah
like because one thing that has aggravated me
about a few of these past series just how kind of
thickheaded the uh uh you know New Republic is in
in a maddening kind of unbelievably cartoonish way
it is maddening and unbelievably cartoonish like I
I understand what they're getting at and like yes
like of course there's going to be bureaucracy of
course it's going to be impossible to get a lot
of things done but like the sheer negligence of
it all is just like so frustrating yeah and to
have a character that like you know supposed
to be this very you know Wise and learned
and calculated tactician I would hope like
that just demands a caliber of writing that the
political leanings of the series have not been
able to satisfy yeah Sabine Ren character Arc
she went from her want was to save Ezra got it
done her need was to believe in herself and grow
and become the force sensitive badass that she
is and she is um I don't feel feel like her Arc
combined with writing and acting was necessarily
a grand slam for me sure out when it needed to it
feels generous uh I mean in all fairness she all
season long she's been holding out her freaking
hand trying to use the force and nothing's been
happening yeah no so it does come in at the
nick nick of time with an emotional up and
and she's like with Ezra there's and she's feel
like she's feeling good about herself she's got
more she's got better things going on you know
she just more light energy yeah you know there
better more reasons to believe in herself in this
moment man it was satisfying uh but the the it's
like it's all there like the arc but it just
there's something that is like borderline flat
to me about the landing Point um other than some
moments that I thought really shined and uh I I
like a lot of her moments especially in action
scenes uh however the there's a little bit one
note of a perform of of like writing and acting
combined it was flat and I didn't want it to be
flat I mean I was really really rooting for her my
favorite character in the show next to Kanan next
to Rebels uh she's my favor I was like what are
you talking about she's my favorite character in
Rebels mexic Canan and and that was a I think of
all the disappointments I felt like they did such
a great job um rera Dawson in particular evolved
and like the intentionality of the character and
how she was able to capture Ahsoka yeah um really
really hit you know and like any reservations I
had in the beginning throughout the full season
Arc with it now in you know in retrospect uh
was perfectly executed whereas Sabine there was
surface level growth but I honestly I just like
there was never chemistry where I wanted it to
be and there was like a little tiny bit with Ezra
but even that like I F like Ezra was holding the
entire weight of that relationship um there was
there's questionable choices on on how to direct
her for certain scenes honestly like it was just
there was a lot of questionable like yeah that
she was yeah dialogue didn't help and questionable
decisions about her like all the times where
she's like withholding information to Ezra and
a lot of it just kind of got chocked up to uh her
like smiling and like pretend like like mirroring
ahsoka's mannerisms of confidence I I understand
you know like I've I've produced and worked on
enough things to know like sometimes when you're
in the middle of it you realize that you might
have made some wrong choices and I I think the
frustrating part is like continue for a long time
to give the benefit of the doubt that lessons
would be learned and that they would make those
slight adjustments to RP the season and I liked
her a lot in the beginning well I I loved her in
the first episode uh which yeah remember the first
episode I was like wow this is great and then it
was just a steady decline honestly from the moment
her and Ahsoka teamed up which really again leads
me to think it was a chemistry issue I liked her
a lot in 137 no when did she find Ezra six six 13
six yeah I like her L but even in it was like it
was good but it wasn't great remember it wasn't I
never yeah I've never been like strongly drawn
to her and and that's a bummer whereas like I
know Rosario Dawson at first was like there's some
things I'm not fully getting and then eventually
like I really get that was that was a that was
a performance choice that needed to like there
was a reason for it and then they explain the
reason and then her character evolved with that
Arc and since then I like I've been just vibing
with Ahsoka like I am bum we did not get to see
them meet in person thraw and Ahsoka we we will
um we will yeah we will we will uh I like that
Ezra got a new lightsaber which inspired by Kanan
I thought was just awesome I did not there were
so many people up in arms about the lightsaber
thing of last week yeah about him not using his
lightsaber like people were like up in arms about
it well I mean it it and I was like what it makes
[__] sense like a guy is going to honestly the
fact that he built the lightsaber at all I thought
was like well that's it's remarkably practical
especially after being gone for so long yeah he
also like if if you know the character of Ezra
he's like he loves to Tinker and build like of
course he wasn't going to take back the lightsaber
he was going to do his own thing CU that's always
been Ezra this is this is his third light saber
no goes through them like a Michael goes through
women that's right man jeez use the force oh no I
mean no no terrible terrible politely obtain the
consent Luke do or do not there is no try yes
or no God damn guys um man that's disgus this
is the show I would say has a better a better
Ensemble than it does individual characters
we need chemistry we need well aside from a
couple darkers has chemistry with everything
I thought like air I thought a sooka and huyang
had better chemistry than Ahsoka and Sabine yes
um has chemistry with everyone hang has chemistry
with everyone Balin and shin were great yeah um
the the last thing we got to talk about night
Troopers this is something I've been waiting for
from the comics forever like and like I I think
they needed to be reserved about it in the best
way that they like I don't know I think they
found a balance that scene was very clunky but
I'll tell you what I think the reason why is they
cut 10 minutes off that way you have to do less
editing these reactors got to get their [__]
up man people doing Break episod um yeah I mean
other than I I guess what we need what we they
really need was other than the fact that they can
be resurrected is like like when you got zombie
horde coming after you the fearers are going to
[__] bite you you know so and here we need to
establish something like it needs to be crystal
sure what makes it more threatening yeah because
it seems like you can still just like strike them
down it just seems like they're more persistent
in that state it's like they're more durable there
there's no like what what I noticed and what gave
like me tension in the moment maybe it didn't come
across to you guys is that they no longer feared
death and so there was this like willingness
Troopers Troopers ever like oh my God they got a
lightsaber I got to get out here there's a when
I say fear death I mean there was an element of
strategy whereas these guys were just like get
close and I don't care how brutal I die but some
of them get close with like no weapon and I'm like
what's there to fear about that well they got to
they could use their helmet to B Bash they might
bite me and it might hurt they might try to bite
me through their mask listen if a stormtrooper
can hold them down long enough maybe one of them
can get a straight shot for once like you know I
don't know yeah I but I did like it when they're
in a hoorde when they are I I when it is a swarm
and you're an individual it's that's when it's
like scary it's the irony of like cuz they charge
yeah it's it made them scarier only I think for
that sake because I think you're absolutely right
like logically speaking unless there's a zombie
virus to transmit what is the threat here except
for the fact that yeah they can just hoard and
and just encroach and well that's what it is in
the expanded universe which is why I'm saying
like I'm grateful for what we got because I
never thought we were going to get zombie Storm
Troopers period and they capture that well when
when the face breaks off and you have the and then
when you also have like Ahsoka trying to fight out
Morgan Elizabeth and dealing with all that uh that
conclave of all that yeah that was kind of Army of
Darkness or something it felt kind of like you
had like a bunch of yeah pure samam well there
was a bit of that like kind of slight Camp to it
at least and you're in like a castle you know like
so my thumbnail is going to be a Anakin Force
ghost I think that won't upset people smiling
we um we're gonna need that'll put the troll face
on his face and then I'll split screen it with the
night I love it I love it uh I'm and then the text
will say Thon wins Emperor Thon thrown I think the
Galaxy would be better off sounds like true seems
like all right guys what did you think about the
Ahsoka finale did you love it did you hate it do
you got to have it do you like it have you been
to menes which frozen yogurt joint do you prefer
Yogurt Land men what's your preferred topping are
we talking are you like a cookie dough Eminem like
a p sizes how would you rate this episode have you
had vegan ice cream leave your thoughts Down Below
guys um hey thanks for having me on for this Greg
will I be ever back yeah of course man we got um
nothing for a long time strikes this is this is a
Star Wars season 3 oh no tales of the Jedi season
2 God tals of oh that's right pass the Christ the
resurrection we already watched Tales of Jedi
season chist no he didn't no that was Visions
dumb ass tell Jedi season two the origin story
is a b the origin story is a Balin um uh who are
they who are they going to recast oh my god oh
dude alen richson I like it from Jack Reacher
guys I'm here for it I um get Ray Winstone does
he have a brother who Ray Stevenson I think it
does Ray there a lot of Stevens yeah Ray winst his
brother us should Ray's the surname yeah they're
Korean secretly sometimes they reorder the names
no wonder it's the only good acting in Star Wars
because it's Korean Stevenson Ray and Winstone
Ray hey let's do a patron of the day shout out
oh I love patrons there's a chat GPT oh John
wants to do the chat gbt that's right like a
kid at the candy store got it said there's a chat
gvt window open for you know how we do here at the
chel out said there chat gvt right there there's
people striking right now trying to end the rider
strike is done we can make fun of chat GB yeah
but the actors well what they're not going to act
with Chad gbt we got this we time all right Lance
door we're going to give you a Star Wars edition
shout out all right Michael give me an article
of clothing Star Wars edition oo uh Leia's bikini
Leia's bikini okay John give me a Star Wars or Hut
Slayer I think is what the official merchandise is
these days okay Hut Slayer and then um John give
me a planet CU I know you can f that um uh uh deoa
oh nice deoa and um give me a how do you spell Deo
you spelled hot hot I thought you said I spelled
it wrong you did there's two t Jesus Christ oh
my God all right we got I got limited time here
daaba the chat supposed to speed up the proc okay
okay all right okay give me uh your favorite Jedi
my favorite Jedi oh my God just give me a Jedi AB
ABW Kenobi OB Obi-Wan Kenobi Obi-Wan Kenobi John
give me um a your favorite Star Wars character
non-jedi Dash renar Dash renar Okay and um all
right give me a a ship a ship uh the eban Hawk
eban Hawk did I spell it right sure did Evan
Hawk all right give me your favorite actor in
Star Wars o uh uh Liam niss Liam niss okay all
right give me your favorite Disney Plus show
from Star Wars my favorite disne oh we're going
Mandalorian no no we're oh my God we're going
bad batch season we're going the bad batch bch
season two the bad batch best Star Wars content
ever made okay all right we're going and then
um lastly an obscure occupation in the Galaxy an
obsc uh a a uh uh uh bantha fodder cleaner upper
cleaner upper oh last one um let's put Chopper
in here as a Droid Chopper sure yeah okay as
a model I have a YouTube channel where I need to
shout out my super sexy reject AKA a patron named
Lance door we want to give him a Star Wars them
themed shout out write me a shout out uh that is
let's go with let's up the game here that is 70
words woo oh that's a lot of words make sure to
incorporate I feel like we included more than 70
words we certainly did incorporate these words
into it all right and let's uh change it to uh 50
words a lot oh here take it away in a Galaxy where
Leia's bikini Hut Slayer uh Reigns Supreme on the
froggy planets of deoa Heroes like Obi-Wan Kenobi
and dash renar fly the ibben hawk but only one
legend lanceor mentored by leam out shines the
bad batch not just a bantha f cleaner upper he's
our Chopper level Patron shout out to you oh my
God it is replacing screenwriters everywhere that
was so genus uh so if you had a choice to write
a new sequel Trilogy Dave filon or chbt um chat
gbt well there you have it chat GPT with a cowboy
rewrite the sequel Trilogy for me in 30 words oh
actually Jesus let's see what they say oh Jesus no
Legacy threatened ancient Sith Secrets emerge
Ray discovers lineage challenges Destiny Finn
Sparks Stormtrooper Revolt kylo seeks Redemption
Force ghosts guide Galaxy unites balance restored
like this is the best tool oh man it it it read
it got a Reddit posted it was just like here we
go thank you guys thank you Lance door I got to
get this video to you got see you soon [Music]